women would rather be the king's
concubine than the peasant's wife I
don't say this in a happy way but the
last couple hundred of years the top 15%
of men have always had concubines
they've always had multiple women
there's a reason King Solomon had like
300 wives um yeah and this is why I say
you know if you date the top 15% of men
don't be shocked if there's someone else
and the solution is don't if you don't
want that then don't date the top 15% of
men pick your poison what the problem is
women just want it all they want
everything and um Are there women that
win the lottery and get everything yes
but don't count on it do you know what I
mean like what are we're going to count
on this you can hope for it you know
hope for the best but you know